نيمار يعطي اوامر مبابي كنت محتجز في
ايطاليا تطورات جديده في قضيه برشلونه هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد خساره نيجرما امام بايرن ميونخ خرج
النجم مبابي وقال بان الفريق عليه ان ياكل
جيدا جيدا للظهور بشكل افضل في مواجهه
الاياب البرازيلي نيمار كان له راي اخر
بعد توجهه الى ماكدونالدز مع اصدقائه
لتناول وجبه سريعه كما انهى سهرته بلاعب
الورق
وفي اخبار نجوم سنجاما ايضا يبدو فريق
انتر ميامي الاقرب للظفر بتوقيع الاسطوره
ليو ميسي بحسب تقارير اعلاميه فرنسيه
وتفضل عائله ميسي الانتقال الى الولايات
المتحده وخاصه الى ميامي التي تعتبر
المدينه الاولى لللاتينيين في امريكا وكان
ميسي قد ابدى سابقا عدم ارتياحه للعيش في
العاصمه الفرنسيه
وبعد خساره فريقه امام ميلا في دوري
الابطال لم يتمكن كونتي من مرافقه فريق
في المدينه الايطاليه بامر المن طبيبه
الخاص بعد كشف روتيني وايضا للراحه بعد
العمليه الجراحيه التي قام بها مطلع الشهر
الجاري وكان النادي الانجليزي قد اصدر
بيانا يؤكد فيه بقاء كونتي في ايطاليا
لدواعي صحيه لكن دون تحديد موعد عودته
في اخر التطورات قضيه الاموال المحوله من
نادي برشلونه اكدت صحيفه اس بان نادي
الكاثولين قد ينجو بفعلته في حال غياب
ادله فعليه تؤكد استفاده الفريق من قرارات
تحكيميه داخل الملعب وكان برشلونه قد اكد
بان الاموال المحوله لشركه الحكم السابق
نيجريرا كانت مقابل النصائح ازدها الاخير
للنادي بحكم موقعه في اللجنه الفنيه
للحكام التابعه للاتحاد الاسباني لكره
القدم